welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and that's phase five of the Multiverse
Saga chugs along toward the track to
Secret Wars many fans of the Beloved
Marvel show Agents of Shield have been
wondering just when their beloved secret
agents will be formally introduced into
the Marvel Cinematic 616 Universe proper
however if a recent tweet from Agents of
Shield actress Chloe Bennett is to be
believed we could very well see The
Return of one Daisy Johnson into this
next phase of Marvel Madness but just
how could Daisy Johnson of the seemingly
separate Agents of Shield Universe be
integrated into Marvel Studios big
budget plans in Phase five I think I've
got a couple pretty plausible ideas here
everybody so let's go over them together
Menard babies but guys I've got to tell
you we've got some dope ass new Quantum
Mania shirts available for you guys over
at New rockstarsmerch.com these shirts
are freaking amazing and there's even
one that I one of my shirt ideas got
made into a shirt it's the one where
Kang looks like the Vitruvian man that's
one of my ideas it brought to life by
one of our amazing designer Partners so
wear that shirt sometimes suit or one of
our other amazing shirts like heading on
over to new roxasmirch.com but today all
right so a recent clap back tweet from
badass actress Chloe Bennett hinted that
we should all very much expect her to
return to Marvel in the nearest Future
despite one Marvel scooper's personal
feelings otherwise the very
mean-spirited Tweet now there are a
couple of direct paths Marvel Studios
could take to have Holly Bennett be
transferred from her ages of Shield
Universe where Inhumans rolled in the
streets and make earth-shattering news
fairly regularly to the mainline MCU
where enhanced mutants have just started
appearing
in the first and most fitting way in my
opinion is of course via the upcoming
second season of Loki a show where we
left Loki off in a completely different
TVA than the one that he spent all of
season one having lunch with Mobius in
now fans of Agents of Shield know that
the final season of that show was
heavily based in time travel as Daisy
Johnson in her Shield Squad were forced
to jump through time as they battled the
nefarious time traveling chronicom
regime and while sure I've been didn't
really have a choice in the matter what
Daisy and her team did during that
season could have had a direct violation
on their universe's TVA timeline meaning
that Daisy Johnson and potentially all
of the Agents of Shield involved could
very well find themselves arrested after
the chaos of all these branching
timelines that this new TVA has to deal
with dies down because if you remember
as Loki runs up to approach Hunter B15
and Mobius all of the TVA seems to be
confused as to why all their timelines
appear to be branching wildly and Hunter
B15 has no idea what the hell is going
on does he want us to just let them all
Branch this chaos of branching timelines
could have opened up the Avenue for
Daisy Johnson and her team to travel
through time without consequences from
the TVA during that season much like all
those branching's heimlines allowed for
the Multiverse events of no way home to
happen over in hiku remains version of
the TVA which is now run by Sylvan like
we're working with two different
timelines then but since Loki's new TVA
seems to still be all about that pruning
timeline's life having Daisy Johnson be
arrested by this team ba as it tries to
regain order would be a natural
continuation of Daisy Johnson's story
while also allowing her to join the MCU
Multiverse narrative and look guys
taking care of yourself is important so
good thing geology makes it easy to do
geology is a 16-time award-winning
personalized skin care company
recognized in hypebeast birdie Men's
Health Esquire and ask man grooming
Awards with over 6 000 5 Star reviews
just take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz and geology will create a simple
and effective skin care or hair care
routine with ingredients that are
dermatologist tested proven to work and
personalized to your needs for Hair Care
geology's got strengthening shampoo and
conditioner and co-wash which will
transform your routine and deliver the
best hair of your life extends the time
between washes and replaces the need for
so many products so you can wash your
hair less and save money more they also
have body washes and deodorants that are
free of harsh ingredients and smell
great for skin care they have you
covered from all angles you can fight
acne reduce oiliness and prevent
wrinkles combat dark or puffy under eyes
have smoother hydrated skin and targets
sign of Aging their daily personalized
skincare routine comes with two face
washes morning face cream retinol night
cream and an eye cream and right now for
a limited time you can get a five piece
trial set for only 15 if you use code
rockstar70 at checkout that's over 150
dollars of product for just 15 and on
top of that you can take an additional
30 bonus off one of their brand new skin
hair and body products of your choice
when you add it to your trial so to get
started just click the link in the
description we thank geology once again
for sponsoring this video but now the
next option that I think Chloe Bennett
has to return to the MCU could be
through a cameo in the upcoming Marvel
movie the Marvels a story that is going
to be centered around the newest Marvel
girl on the Block Kamala Khan aka Miss
Marvel because remember how at the
beginning of episode 3 of Miss Marvel
when the clandestines took Miss Marvel's
Bengals off of mysterious blue arm under
a pile of rubble in the year 1942. many
people have suspected that arm to belong
to a member of the alien Cree race and I
believe that this could very well be the
case as well potentially a part of that
Sleeper Cell of Cree that Talos Fury
mentioned briefly in Spider-Man far from
home I thought Cree having sleeper cells
was top secret information I think that
these Cree hidden on Earth in the
distant past could have been that very
same Sleeper Cell that Talos was
referring to a Sleeper Cell of Cree
experimenting on humans to create the
super-powered inhuman mutation within
Humanity a mutated race brought to the
Forefront recently when Black Bolt was
brought to the big screen for the first
time ever and it was pretty dope and he
killed Doctor Strange it was very sad
but very cool this being said much like
they have for the X-Men I feel like
Marvel Studios very much has beat humans
on the mind as well as they progress
this Narrative of different
super-powered genetic mutations popping
up in the MCU and this potential Sleeper
Cell of science Cree experimenting with
the cosmic energy manipulating
Technologies of these bracelets on
mankind could pave the way for the 616
Universe in humans to start appearing as
well with a 616 variant of Daisy Johnson
potentially getting their power sometime
during the Marvel's movie because that
movie is going to be all about the cree
race and you have to remember that Ronan
did promise that he was going to come
back to earth for that secret weapon and
I don't think he just meant Captain
Marvel I think he meant all of humanity
in the potential to become super powered
beings the cree really want that because
they themselves cannot evolve like
Humanity can but another way I can think
of how Quake could return to the MCU is
through the continued Narrative of Earth
838 an earth that had the leader of the
inhuman people assassinated in the most
brutal way possible by an Invader From
Another Universe so knowing that Daisy
Johnson is an inhuman herself in the
Agents of Shield Universe there is a
chance that Daisy Johnson could have
lived in the inhuman Kingdom of adelan
and served under or in conjunction with
Black Bolt and the inhuman royal family
and with these Inhumans just suffering a
massive loss of their king and the
promise of Multiverse incursions on the
way in the MCU a clashing between Earth
616 and Earth 838 seems almost
inevitable as the road to Secret Wars
continues on so I believe that there is
a big opportunity here for Quake to be
one of the main many people from Earth
838 who want Vengeance against the
Scarlet Witch of Earth 616 for killing
their leader or just another one of
their Heroes like freaking the Fantastic
three are coming for the Scarlet Witch
like my God the Fantastic three the
X-Men the Inhumans who else if everyone
Captain Marvel helped uh mordo but I do
this after everybody anyway
but finally the last way that I can
think of Quake being introduced into the
MCU is through a potential secret
Warriors Project after Nick Fury's
secret Invasion project with the secret
Warriors being a secret Rogue team of
obscure super power people that Nick
Fury could actually trust that he formed
after he realized that anyone on the
planet could be a scroll as more and
more super powered mutants pop up in the
MCU we could see Nick Fury recruiting a
616 version of Daisy Johnson whose
Powers just manifested onto his new MCU
secret Warriors team I mean there have
been rumors of a potential secret
Warriors Project in the works in Marvel
Studios but considering where we're at
in the MCU with squirrels and sketchy
people like Contessa Valentina
devontaine I think that Nick Fury now
has little people that he can actually
trust and he definitely needs his own
Avengers type team to fight squirrels
and maybe even potentially Val's
Thunderbolts if he needs to and a daisy
Johnson variant is a shoe-in for a comic
accurate secret Warriors team in the
mainline MCU but those are the ways that
I believe Chloe Bennett could make her
way from the TV Universe to the MCU
Cinematic Universe proper but what do
you guys think how do you guys think
that Chloe Bennett will be integrated
into the MCU because it very much seems
like that is what Chloe Bennett is
expecting but thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertainment on Twitter if you guys
want to see me tweet some weird [__] but
most importantly we can follow new
rockstars wherever we are on the social
medias and when you do here on YouTube
make sure you hit that notification Bell
so you can get notifications every time
we upload a video and of course do not
forget to hit up new rockstarsmerch.com
so you can get one of these cool Quantum
Mania shirts or whatever other amazing
nerd options over there so go to new
rocksystems.com today but again thank
you guys so much for watching this video
love you guys so much and I'll see you
guys next time goodbye
foreign
[Music]